and finally new rule don't throw the
synthetic baby out with the bathwater
last week you may have seen that the
iconic designers Dolce and Gabanna
caused a ruckus when they said that even
though they're proudly gay when it comes
to how are you make it to Bambino
they're old-school Italians who don't
approve of what they called synthetic
children because you know synthetics
they just don't breathe like cotton well
naturally a backlash ensued and now
people are refusing to wear this shirt
and you know what so am i but nothing
but not because I'm protesting something
because I'm not Persian
yes we joke about everybody here and
that's something a lot of liberals have
forgotten how to do for folks who take
such pride in their love of diversity
liberals increasingly seem to tolerate
none in their own ranks I don't
necessarily agree with Dolce and Gabanna
but what is the point of attacking
people who are 95 percent on your side
give them a break they're from Sicily
the same place Justice Scalia comes from
and if you want a protest someone who
doesn't support gays start with him but
but no it's easier to get all fake
outraged over the hateful anti-gay
speech of two men who bedazzled
codpieces for a living Elin Martina they
were all furious Courtney Love said she
planned to burn her Dolce & Gabbana and
then breathe in the melting polyester
cuz hey you never know what might get
you hot but Dame Elton John was the
angriest of all tweeting how dare you
refer to my children is synthetic my
hair yes but my children he recorded a
protest song cold I won't let my son go
down on you
and called for a boycott really you
can't sell handbags now if you only
agree without John almost all the time
and Syria Isis is throwing gay people
off buildings
maybe there are bigger battles to fight
we liberals always talk about how the
right needs to rein in its crazies but
the left has some crazy ran in in to do
to unless you think I'm creating a false
equivalency
I'm not because on the right unlike the
left they have actually managed to carve
out a place for their crazies
unfortunately that place is elected
government all the more reason not to
drive people into their arms with crazy
political correctness for example The
Economist last week drew the wrath of
the liberal website Media Matters who
said that their jalapeno flag cover was
the sort of stereotype that ignores
Latinos as a multi-faceted community and
relegates them to chili pepper consuming
constituent hey Media Matters can I say
one thing to you shut the [ __ ] up
no Hispanic looked at this cover and
said I've been wronged they looked at it
and said hmm YUM jalapeno look at this
insane headline college president forced
to apologize after saying all lives
matter you know what happened a college
president sent out an email in support
of the protesters in Ferguson but said
all lives matter instead of black lives
matter and then had to apologize I'm
sorry I I meant black lives [ __ ] all
lives how deeply stupid has the far-left
become when gay designers can't get
along with gay musicians when vegans
attack vegetarians for not being pure
enough I've seen this cheese eater burn
him
I see agnostics and atheists bitching at
each other why is this even a thing do
you believe in a talking snake
me neither we're on the same team okay
one more at Mount Holyoke this year they
canceled a production of the Vagina
Monologues because they said it offended
the transgendered by offering quote an
extremely narrow perspective on what it
means to be a woman yes we forgot all
about the 0.3 percent of women who don't
have vaginas but still want a monologue
I'm I'm sorry I love the transgendered
but if you're transgendered and you
can't handle the Vagina Monologues
you don't need a vagina you're already a
giant [ __ ]